sometimes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
as a woman in Qatar I feel very safe and
I can go out on my own and not feel
worried about about anything any time of
the day or night you can walk around you
don't have to worry and there's Ubers or
this guy you don't have to worry I love
how can I just walk either with my
husband or alone and I know that no one
will like approach me
[Music]
it's the most controversial World Cup in
history and a ball hasn't even been
kicked Cattery society and cultures
based heavily on a strict interpretation
of Islamic law and an ancient tribal
system yeah I was a bit worried about
um some stuff that's in sort of
westernized media before I came over and
I'd plan to outfits to sort of
accommodate the culture over here and um
so yeah that's the only thing I've sort
of had to alter but it's all been fine I
think it was the unknown was the name I
think it's worked out a lot better than
what probably thinking it me I think
before coming I'd heard a lot about the
Middle East being restrictive but like
the news maybe seemed like Qatar and
Dubai are a little bit more westernized
so I packed a lot of shorts I did pack a
lot of jackets but when I got here I
felt more comfortable
[Music]
oh it's a little bit worried about what
to wear and what like what I wasn't
allowed to wear but everything I bought
no one's ever looked at anything and it
was just felt really safe other
experience probably had today where I
felt a bit uncomfortable was when I went
out in some shops
um but apart from that I think
everything else has been
[Music]
no just kind of the the looks are just
the kind of the way that I was meant to
feel I think real and I didn't feel like
anyone was ever telling me I should be
wearing something different
um or that there were restrictions I did
notice some signs like we went to the
museum today and I felt like there were
some signs there advising women what
they needed to wear
[Music]
beer will be banned inside stadiums in
the conservative Muslim country for me
beer and football would go hand in hand
everybody says oh they come hand in hand
that's not the case because there's lots
of fights and violence with alcohol I
think that in Qatar they did the right
they made the right decision you haven't
got that fear of like it's gonna you're
gonna get caught in something Rowdy or
you're going to get shouted out by men
that are really drunk and stuff like
that so I guess yeah for for women it's
definitely going to be a nicer
experience
foreign
[Applause]